Donald Trump has a ton of crazy theories
which he's willing to say publicly and
it turns out that much like with many
people this is actually not that rare
there's an entire other even crazier
narrative of what he's willing to say
privately and share with his inner
circle and there's a New York magazine
piece that exposes a lot of this stuff
and we're linking to that piece so
earlier this week we learned from what
was an I believe a Vanity Fair piece
that Donald Trump is concerned that
journalists traveling on Air Force One
my sort of weaponized the virus and
deliberately infect him with it that's
already pretty wacky and Donald Trump
now we have learned privately is raging
about all sorts of completely absurd
notions for example Trump privately is
furious that he's not getting credit for
stopping travel from China now of course
he did it way too late only partially we
found countless flights still landing in
the United States from China after Trump
said he had cut it off Trump privately
is raging at the media for even covering
what is now a pandemic / the w-h-o and
is convinced that the media simply is
out to get Trump no dude you're bungling
everything you're doing everything wrong
even the things you're doing you're
lying about Trump believes / the New
York Magazine magazine piece either
because he decided or people convinced
him Trump believes he is personally way
healthier than both Bernie Sanders and
Joseph R Biden Jr and that therefore
he's less at risk of the virus or if he
were to catch the virus this is the
president who lies about his height to
avoid being clinically obese
the president who doesn't exercise the
president who eats endless fast food and
barely walks around and the president
who had to have cauliflower mixed into
his mashed potatoes to get some actual
vegetables into his diet
he thinks he's healthier than Joe Biden
and Bernie Sanders now if you watched
his address to the nation on Wednesday
evening you probably noticed that his
right eye as I mentioned was almost
completely swollen shut you might have
known
that he was with experiencing labored
breathing he didn't look well but in any
case he thinks he's gonna be fine but
Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden won't if
they catch the disease very very weird
Donald Trump believes that the virus
isn't really that big of a threat
because his friends don't yet have it
and his friends don't yet know people
who have it Trump believes that without
any intervention the virus situation may
indeed solve itself which is of course
not how pandemics work pandemics require
interventions and Donald Trump's entire
public spectacle may it may seem to be
merely from political pressure not
because Donald Trump actually believes
that it is necessary this is why these
things spread so quickly before we
understood germ theory and the like
people didn't realize that our actions
are what determine what happens that you
have to look at you know is water
spreading a disease is it contact is it
airborne is it aerosolized is it via
bodily fluids what wouldn't you know
understanding the stuff washing hands
when the world of Medicine understood oh
when you wash your hands between
patients at the hospital you're much
better off obviously it's not clear what
of any of this stuff Donald Trump
believes and that's why this last belief
is the most outrageous one because if
Donald Trump deep down believes that
without human intervention this is all
going to resolve itself then it's going
to continue to spread while he does the
absolute minimum or lies in front of the
public that he you know that insurance
companies have decided to waive all
co-pays for treatment when in fact they
have not this is horrifying this is
scary stuff we have very little that we
can do to change his mind since he's in
an isolated echo chamber of brown-nosing
and Fox News and it seems as though if
the New York magazine piece is to be
believed it seems as though even the
things he is doing he's doing out of
political pressure and political
posturing and because the stock market
is imploding not because he actually
believes that it's necessary his
ignorance has a body count associated
with it and sometimes when we say a body
count we mean a political body count
people who have lost their their
positions they weren't reelected because
of something that
Donald Trump did which had a
trickle-down effect no no we're talking
about an actual body count here and in
the meantime again let's start testing I
know Trump believes if the number of
cases explodes which it would if we
start testing because the ton of people
already have it if that were to happen
Trump thinks it would be terrible for
him and maybe it would in some sense but
the important thing is that would show
that this is less deadly and it would
also really encourage people who might
be asymptomatic to self quarantine and
to stay home people who otherwise would
never be tested we've got to start
testing large numbers of people this is
not going to get any better for as long
as this buffoon is in charge unless
people can take control for themselves
and so far it doesn't seem that the
Trump administration is allowing anybody
to do that let me know once again what
are you doing are you modifying your
behavior because of the virus are you
changing your day to day let me know on
Twitter I'm on Twitter at D Pakman make
sure that you are following me there we
have a very very big program for you
today I am going to be hearing from
people in the audience about what's
going on with the primary we are still
in the middle of a primary despite the
fact that we are also in the middle of
dealing with a pandemic crisis and much
more coming up today what if you could
read ten books in just one sitting
that's exactly what one of my favorite
apps lets you do it's called blinka Stan
what they do is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books they condense
them down into text or audio that you
can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire non-fiction book in
just 15 minutes
I recently checked out the book podcast
marketing strategy by Daniel rolls and
Ciaran Rogers and so useful so
particularly applicable to what I'm
doing really recommended blink East has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non
fiction categories and a subscription is
only about eight bucks a month and you
get the entire library but you can try
it totally free and get 25% off a
subscription when you go to blink is
comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video